Providing shoppers with a chance to buy and
transport goods across international boundaries
without paying local and national taxes, duty-free
shops are found in airports and other ports
and stations around the world.
A creation of the 20th century, duty-free
shops mark a sharp departure from more than
2,000 years of nations generating revenue
by taxing the trade in commodities and other
goods.
The practice of imposing such taxes traces
its origins to at least the ancient Greeks
and Romans where duties were levied on a wide
variety of imports and exports.
As leaders through the ages recognized that
this was an easy and efficient way to collect
revenue, the custom remained popular even
among the so-called barbarians who conquered
the great early civilizations.
By the Middle Ages, feudal lords were still
imposing taxes on the goods that passed in
and out of (and by) their lands, and out of
this tradition arose both toll gates and customs
houses.
In fact, by the 1300s, the word costom and
custume had taken the meaning of a rent, tribute
or tax paid to a feudal lord or other local
authority (such as a king’s representative).
The word duty, meaning something due or owed,
dates to the end of the 13th century, while
the denotation of duty as a tax was first
recorded in the late 15th century.
Duty-free, as an adjective, dates back to
the late 1600s, where it referred to a taxing
authority agreeing to forego taking its usual
fee.
The idea of exempting certain goods from import/export
taxes as a matter of routine, however, is
a relatively recent invention.
Born out of the recognition that the dramatic
increase in international, civilian travel
(and in particular air travel) after World
War II could produce significant revenue,
specifically from tourism, one innovative
Irishman conceived of the idea of placing
tax-free shops in international airports.
In 1947, Brendan O’Regan convinced the Irish
government to pass a law that made the transit
area of Shannon Airport (where he served as
Catering Comptroller) as technically not a
part of Ireland, and, therefore, any purchases
made there wouldn’t be subject to tax.
Passed on March 18, 1947, the Customs-Free
Airport Act made Shannon Airport the first
duty-free port in the world.
Although initially Shannon Airport’s sales
were limited to Irish linen and other locally-produced
goods, Regan and company quickly realized
that if they stocked other international goods
and sold those duty-free as well, they would
fly off of the shelves.
Prominent brand names early-on included Dior,
Chanel, Hummel, Minox and Waterford.
So popular was the practice that within a
decade, duty-free had also begun to be used
as a noun to denote the goods purchased in
the shop.
Other duty-free shops followed, including
those established by the American company,
Duty Free Shoppers (DFS) in Hong Kong in 1960
and in Hawaii in 1962 (the first duty-free
shop in the United States).
Note that duties are not only imposed by an
exporting country, but may be levied when
you enter a country, as well.
The United States imposes duties on a wide
variety of purchases, although there are exemptions,
depending on where you purchased or received
the item, how long you were there, your residency
status and the value of the goods.
For example, a US resident who has spent at
least 48 hours abroad is usually able to bring
back $800 worth of goods without tax, with
the next $1,000 worth of goods taxed at a
3% rate, and anything more than that taxed
according to a tariff schedule; if the US
resident did not spend at least 48 hours in
the foreign country, the base exemption amount
reduces to only $200.
On the other hand, for US residents, the exemption
doubles for imports from US insular possessions
(e.g., Guam).
Note that the rules and exemption amounts
are a bit different for non-residents visiting
the US who bring goods with them.
Of course, there are exceptions to the exemption,
and certain goods, like alcohol and tobacco,
are treated differently, depending on the
product and the country where it was purchased.
For example, US residents returning from Europe
with one liter or less of alcohol may bring
that in duty-free.
It is important to remember that duty-free
only applies to goods purchased for personal
use, not for resale, and the taxes imposed
on the latter (and any exemptions) will be
governed by other laws, regulations and trade
agreements such as the Generalize System of
Preferences (GSP) and the North American Free
Trade Agreement (NAFTA).